the front line of the crackdown on covet
rule breakers
police in birmingham raid an illegal
nightclub in the heart of the city
complete with its own vip area
150 people were inside and some revelers
pelted officers with bottles
before trying to escape by climbing the
roof
[Applause]
70 people will find 200 pounds and
police say the dj could face a
10 000 pound penalty for breaking
lockdown rules
eight miles down the road in dudley port
detectives were tipped off about a
coveted arms
a car garage converted into a makeshift
pub
[Music]
do you mind turning that off for us
please if i put it bluntly
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
eleven twelve thirty a dozen drinkers
were allowed to leave
the owner was fined a thousand pounds
the police crackdown on mass gatherings
has been stepped up across the country
during the pandemic
back in august officers dispersed this
illegal wave in birmingham
where two marquis had been set up and
just 10 days ago
police broke up a party attended by more
than 150 students on campus in sheffield
back in everybody backing everybody in
back in
and as hopes grow for an easing of
restrictions soon
authorities are keen to emphasize that
sticking to the rules
is more important than ever milena
veselinovich
sky news